welcome back
to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel and podcast
today we're gonna have a conversation
with a cyber security professional
today we're going to have a conversation
andy smith i've been planning a
conversation on ml devops for quite some
time
and i recorded loads of footage with aws
but it turns out that i've got about
five
hours worth of footage and i need to
approve that footage with aws before i
publish it
and the conversation i had with andy all
about threat modeling and security for
machine learning
i just felt like it was a great
conversation and it stood on its own two
feet anyway i hope you enjoyed the
conversation
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments and we'll
see you back
next week so i am here with andy smith
a cyber security professional in the
industry
hello andy hi tim how's it going
very good indeed andy we're making a
show all about ml devops
and um one of the things that
exasperates me about ml devops is i
think people haven't really seen it done
at scale
and in the context of a large
organization i mean in my opinion
mo devops is mostly process and one of
the most
important processes is security and in a
large organization how would an ml
devops team
engage with the cyber security folks i
think it very much depends on the
setup of an organization in some
organizations
the security function is a completely
separate team
in which case there'll be some kind of
defined interface
for typically raising an engagement with
those security folks to get their input
on a certain activity
in other organizations the expectation
is the
developers who are creating the system
will have a very
very strong understanding of the
security factors that affect their
particular solution
the reality is hey it's usually a bit of
both
in the you know we would hope that our
developers have a pretty good
understanding of the security of the
systems they're building
but there might be certain specialist
areas where they need a security pro to
come in and
give them some prompts in the right
direction that's awesome
it feels a bit overwhelming to me
because you know what makes devops so
difficult especially in machine learning
is
the multi-disciplinary teams and all of
the different systems you're touching
so on one end of the system you're
ingesting data from a data platform
and large companies typically have a
data platform
on its own they have a a monolithic data
platform probably one on every single
cloud provider
and they have data engineering kind of
platform team
and they have lots of data management
and security and stuff and then you know
you've got
your data engineering pipelines and and
you've got your ml devops systems and
then on the other end you've got how you
productionize the models and and so on
so
it it it just seems like an entire
universe of complexity so where do you
even start
yeah absolutely systems are massively
complicated and
even more so when we're talking about ai
and ml systems
so one of the approaches that we
typically recommend from a cyber
security point of view to help deal with
some of that complexity
and to help identify where there might
be
cyber security flaws in a system is a
process called threat modeling
and this is something that we all do on
a daily basis
as part of our normal lives you know
when we're crossing the road we threaten
model the situation to work out whether
we're gonna get
run over or not um but we humans we're
not
necessarily always particularly great at
doing that in a
accurate and pragmatic way for example a
lot of people have a fear of flying
because i think oh no the plane's going
to crash i'm going to die
whereas the statistics show that you're
far more likely
to be seriously injured in a car
accident than
an aircraft accident so we know humans
are not necessarily
great at judging risk so
to help that usually a threat modeling
process
will try and structure people's thinking
around the cybersecurity threats of a
system
so instead of chucking a bunch of
developers
in a room and saying tell us about the
security problems
go the threat modeling frameworks will
try and provide a much more structured
methodology for thinking about
where those flaws might appear and where
we have really really complex systems
well hey you know you could get stuck
down in the weeds very quickly
so for an initial threat modelling
exercise maybe we
force everyone to think about 50 000
foot view
of okay maybe let's segment an
application into some really high level
chunks of say
when we're talking about say an ml
pipeline system maybe we've got a
dev environment we've got a production
environment and then we've got our
users that may be sitting on the other
end of the internet somewhere
and will draw trust boundaries between
each of those
big parts of a system and then drill
down for each of those trust boundaries
talk about the specific factors that
might affect the cyber security of a
system
now of course there are definitely going
to be other trust boundaries at a lower
level
in each of those main blocks but at
least by starting off at that top level
view
we get a bit of an idea of the overall
security of this system and some of the
main threats
and then we can drill down into some of
those other areas in more detail
in subsequent sessions that's really
interesting the first thing i get from
that is there is a degree of pragmatism
because you can't possibly take
everything to the nth degree because you
would never make any
progress and i love this concept of risk
management
because it's the same framework we
actually use for ai
ethics or for compliance and legals and
and stuff like that it's about having
stakeholders
make an assessment about what the state
of players at a particular time
the other thing i wanted to get to is
you spoke about these trust boundaries
and i suppose the way you engage with a
team would depend on their level of
maturity
so if i were to design an ml devops
system there would be certain principles
that it would need to abide by
for example ephemeral stateless
architecture and using a lot of the
the cloud architecture design principles
like for example
elastic auto scale but one of the the
principal things is isolation
so i would have a separate dev and
production environment
and a lot of this is about kind of
saying how do we contain a problem
so even if the dev environment got
um taken over by an adversary how could
we
contain that but this exercise that
you're discussing would
highlight those issues yeah absolutely
so
the uh the threat modeling process will
try and identify the various sources of
threats
which you can then push into a risk
management process to decide
what you're going to do about them in
some cases
the risk is very significant you know we
feel like it's highly likely
that a particular threat will be
exploited and actually the impact could
be quite high
so we should definitely do something
about this in other cases
maybe the risk is quite low so therefore
we
simply accept that that's going to
happen
so i know you and i have spoken about
a number of uh specific threat scenarios
for
ml models previously and on previous
episodes of the show tim you've spoken
about adversarial examples
and that's an area which i think the
conclusion of that episode was
yeah it's a thing in the lab but does it
happen in real life
not really and so that may be a great
case where
you know a a devops team uh decide
actually no you know we know that
potentially our model
might be affected by
a adversarial example but
we are intentionally not going to do
anything about it because actually we've
got a much bigger problem elsewhere you
know maybe
maybe we're not using multi-factor
authentication for any of our access and
we believe that that is going to be a
much bigger threat to us
i think that's fascinating because it
does come down to the fundamentals i
think a lot of people when they read or
when they talk about ml security they
have this rather fanciful view
that the problem is going to be
adversaries you know perturbing image
inputs to
take over our systems and and actually
it's a little bit more mundane than that
as you say it's things like multi-factor
authentication and
security containers the other thing is
the dream of devops is to kind of
automate everything but i think that's a
myth
um actually when you have a large
organization and lots of different
systems and people
it's all about process and a lot of that
is
interactive it's manual so you might
have teams that have to go to
a site where they fill out a form in
order to get some cloud architecture and
so on
and when you do the threat modeling
sessions a lot of the threats that come
up are
around those kind of those kind of
attack vectors basically where either
inadvertently or maliciously
people put the wrong thing in those
forms and and they
subvert the process that we've designed
yeah i think there's a there's
definitely a blend
of intentional malicious activity that
needs to be guarded against
and also like the fat finger syndrome
you know accidentally
doing the wrong thing yeah the the kind
of threats that come up in practice
are not what you would expect actually
some of them just come down to the kind
of security fundamentals that you
probably have dealt with for the last 15
years
um a lot a lot of it is maybe trust
boundaries are the right way to describe
this but when you have
people and systems and organizational
boundaries and you know flows of
information that transgresses these
boundaries
that's almost where you have the
potential for people to um exploit your
system
and in some sense the it doesn't matter
that it's a machine learning i mean
machine learning systems are more
complicated of course but it seems to be
going back to those security
fundamentals yeah absolutely there's
there's nothing inherently about a an ml
system
from a devops point of view that is
really that different to any other
system
there's still code that you need to
protect and if someone modifies that
code then they can change the operation
of your system
there's still data that needs to be
protected
maybe because otherwise you know you
will end up in
regulatory issues if it's privacy
related information or
maybe you know you generally your
business suffers if uh
records that are meant to be accurate
and modified and all of these types of
things is
almost coming back to classic
confidentiality integrity availability
type problems that
we've been looking at in cyber security
for many many years
i think there are some aspects of an ml
system
that introduce some unique
security vulnerabilities and
we again we've spoken about these before
tim these are ones that
can feel like they're slightly contrived
they're kind of like they're
quite academic type threats uh things
like adversarial examples
and whilst i would probably
agree with the fact that these are going
to be
lower risk items in the grand scheme of
things
today the question is well what are
those threat vectors going to look like
tomorrow
when we get further down the line will
those
adversarial examples simply be
remembered
as a cool little trick that you used to
be able to play with ml systems
or is that actually turning into a
genuine threat
that we need to be very very guarded
against and may be doing a lot more than
we are doing today
yeah i think we shouldn't be dismissive
that was something that surprised me so
when we spoke to florian tremor
and nicholas carlini from google they
almost dismissed it
they just said that they haven't seen
this in the wild at all no
florian drama wrote a paper about how
folks were using it to disrupt ad
blockers
so you now get these perceptual ad
blockers and the
there actually is a kind of a reason to
disrupt the blockers there so the
advertisers will add some
imperceptible noise to their ads to to
fool the blockers so that was a great
example but
they said they're not seeing it used in
practice but the end of the day if you
have an adversary out there
then they will exploit it's almost like
if you've got a
castle wall and there are weaknesses in
the wall then your adversaries will go
straight to those weaknesses if they're
not doing it now
they will do it later so i think the
fact that no one's doing it in the world
at the moment isn't a reason not to take
it seriously absolutely and
i mean an attacker will always try and
go after the
the weakest part of the system um you
know they've they've got time
uh they've got a limited amount of money
maybe they want to maximize
their opportunity for doing bad stuff
so whilst again today the
more traditional threats of have you got
the right kind of firewalling
are you checking for sql injection are
you using mfa all these classic things
are certainly going to be big gaping
holes in that
nice castle perimeter today if they're
missing
that's not to say that the the more
creative adversarial examples and other
ml specific attack vectors
are just non-existent they they
certainly are there
and i kind of maybe draw some parallels
here
with cryptography so if you ask most
cyber security people they'll have a
good understanding of cryptography in
terms of
oh you know you've maybe got symmetric
and asymmetric algorithms
oh and you've got hashing versus
encryption you know
most security people will understand to
a good level with the foundations
but almost no one in security will be
able to tell you exactly how does aes
256 work
what is the exact order of operations
and what are the specific threats you
know uh that
would open that up to
some kind of compromise so what we end
up with
is a bunch of people that know enough to
do their jobs
so for example i can tell you you
absolutely should not use the md5 hash
because it's terribly badly broken
can i undertake a real life md5 hash
collision
in the wild uh hey that's really really
tough to do
and i kind of see parallels like i say
with some of these machine learning
threats as well
i think it's important that those who
are developing them
understand enough of what they need to
know today
in order to defend their systems well
because there are going to be a very
small number of very very skilled people
out there
who do know a lot more and can actually
implement some of these attacks in the
world yeah i think that's fair
and that's actually a great example
because we were talking a little bit
about well maybe it's just coming back
to security fundamentals but
there is something a bit different about
ml devops and it's what you just
highlighted
it's the sense that there's a lot of
fragmentation of knowledge
and you have these multi-disciplinary
teams and the ml engineers and software
engineers probably don't
know anything about the underlying
algorithms and
probably the data scientists will even
use even more complex models just to
interpret
the machine learning models and again
you need to have expert knowledge to
understand those
those um interpretability methods so
you're in this situation now where we're
having to rely on interfaces and testing
and we have this kind of sausage factory
and no one
in that particular part of the sausage
understands how the rest of the sausages
are made
uh what could possibly go wrong and with
machine learning systems
as well as having the code we now have
data and models
and both of those things are kind of
changing
all the time so it it does make things
significantly more complicated i suppose
absolutely and i guess that is one of
the unique things of a machine learning
system
we don't program a machine learning
system by saying
if this then that we provide it with a
bunch of data
it goes off and does its training
process and produces something
and then well how do we verify
that what has been produced is accurate
and reliable
well we have to go through a lot of
testing
in order to gain confidence that it's
gonna
operate fairly reliably in the wild
but if you compare that to a
traditionally programmed system of a
if this then that type statement then
that's something that's
really provable you can write very very
specific test cases for that
and you can have confidence 100
confidence
that a system is going to work in a
certain way
and for me that's where one of the
bigger challenges
around machine learning security comes
in and machine learning reliability
comes in
is that element of unpredictability the
fact that
you have input spaces that are so
unimaginably vast that is just not
feasible
to test every part of that input space
so there needs to be a i guess a middle
ground there in terms of
how much testing do you do to have
confidence to use an ml model
in production but then there's an
element of
well what is that model being used for
and are you happy for there to be a
certain element of unpredictability
in that or do you need to start
including humans in the loop
or that kind of thing it comes back to
this whole accountability for decision
making
are you happy that a machine will make a
decision
or do you want that machine simply to
make a recommendation to a human
who actually is then accountable for the
decision oh you're getting onto
something really interesting there
actually which is
you know how you design the overall uh
process of how ai is used but
before that you were talking about the
uh the size of the state space
and it's not necessarily even that
actually because if if you ask
a software engineer to create the game
of tetris
how long would it take they would say i
don't know probably a few weeks
if you think about it how many unique
state spaces are there in tetris it's
huge
right it doesn't matter the reason why
software is better is because you can
decompose it into smaller sub-problems
and you can
walk through the code of a debugger and
you can kind of understand in some sense
what's going on
whereas with machine learning you've got
no chance but another example is a
sorting algorithm
how many permutations of numbers are
there but we still trust that the
sorting algorithm will generalize to
every permutation of
numbers that you could put in in a list
and we write a few tests and we just
trust that those tests are going to work
but machine learning is a completely
different ball game absolutely yeah
and like i said it's that element of
unpredictability that
certainly from a security person's point
of view
is one of the concerns because how
if you can't say that a system is going
to operate
reliably then yeah that's
that's obviously a concern right and i
guess it depends on the nature of the
system
you know if a system is being used for
i don't know helping you decide what
sandwich you want to order for lunch
that's probably not a big deal if it's
being used
that could in a way that could
potentially be used
for someone's life or death decisions
then you clearly want a lot more
reliability there and
that's something that will obviously
need to be taken into account
when we start having some of these
conversations about okay
you've identified a threat to your
system what are we going to do about it
in cases for the the sandwich ordering
machine we might say
actually the impact is so small even if
it is gonna happen
you know one in five times the impact is
so small
we don't care about it whereas for more
serious decisions
clearly we want very very high
reliability
absolutely and and something that i
think i hope comes out of this
conversation for folks that are
listening is
i mean andy's a security person but
actually what he's talking about applies
to
explainability methods it applies to
legal and compliance and so on actually
that this this mindset of risk
management is thinking about
the consequences of your system in
production
what could go wrong and how could that
affect us and what do we need to do
about it
and it's so much more than you might
think of security as just being these
kind of bad actors trying to exploit
your system but it's so much more than
that it's
you know we we might need to give
explanations of why we don't give credit
to someone otherwise the regulator you
know could find
us lots of money and and we could go out
of business it it's actually
all-encompassing but andy i wanted to
get to this threat modeling exercise so
imagine i came to you with an ml devops
architecture
and we went through this modeling
exercise how would you go about doing
that
so i think the first thing would be to
understand at a high level view what is
the overall architecture of your
solution
and normally this would be through a
system diagram or a data flow diagram
and as i spoke about before we probably
want to start off at a fairly high level
view
and chunk a system up into reasonable
sized
areas and and then define on that where
trust
boundaries exist so this is where one
part of the system has to interface with
another part of a system
which it does not control or there is a
significant difference in trust level so
for example
the difference between a dev system and
a production system
there's clearly a trust boundary there
or
any system that you connect to the
internet
there's a trust boundary on that line
where you connect to the internet
because there's a whole bunch of
horrible bad damaging things that exist
on the internet so once we've got that
high level kind of picture and i find
pictures do work really well here
maybe it's me i'm a very visual person
so having an actual diagram of a system
really really useful so having had that
uh we then start to look at each of the
interfaces across a truss boundary and
use a formal methodology to explore
some of the potential threats there for
folks that are getting started with
threat modeling
the stride methodology is quite a good
one
as a methodology developed by by
microsoft
and stride is an acronym and it
basically calls out the factors that you
should
ask yourself about the the flow of data
across a trust boundary the s stands for
spoofing
is it possible to
make one side believe that it's talking
to the other side
that it but actually it's someone bad
so can can you pretend to be part of one
side of that conversation
uh the t stands for tampering is it
possible for
a bad actor to modify information as it
transits across that trust boundary
the r stands for repudiation which is
around
is it possible to state with certainty
that a particular action did or did not
take place
so a good example here is around
financial transactions
where that transaction is occurring
across a trust boundary
can you prove that it definitely did or
did not take place
um i stands for integrity and is it
possible to
modify a information inside a data store
again usually if one interface is right
one side of an interface is writing to
the other side of an interface you know
you could
you could tamp with data in that way
and the d is a denial of service
so is there a method for preventing
access to
one side of that trust boundary
so a classic example here would be oh um
how do we prevent or rather
there is a risk that there's some bad
actors on the internet that might
flood our internet connection with a
load of junk traffic so our
service is no longer usable and finally
e stands for elevation of privilege so
is it possible across that trust
boundary to
make one side promote its access to a
higher level
than it should otherwise have access to
which would then
potentially allow an attacker to access
other information or modify other parts
of the system
so that stride framework just gives a a
few ideas
for the participants in a threat modern
exercise to think about in a structured
way
rather than necessarily going with gut
feel
which as we spoke about with the
airplane versus driving risk example
isn't always a reality yeah
that's really interesting so i'm trying
to get a an image of how this works
in in a large organization there are
jurisdiction boundaries
which means ml devops is quite
interesting actually because it's
a meta vehicle it's something that it
doesn't really have anything
tangible it might be a bunch of
infrastructure as code scripts
you know so you you can you can create
these environments it's like the recipe
right
but actually there's the actual system
that you create
so those are all of the downstream
projects and then all of those projects
will talk to
many of the other systems in the company
like you know the data platform and
various other platforms so from a
jurisdiction point of view
my virtual team my data you know ml
let's say my ml devops team
only has access to the templates so what
do we do do we do we draw out an
information architecture
and the nodes in that architecture are
people and systems
and there's a jurisdiction boundary
which represents what we can control
and then all of the interfaces between
those things those are the trust
boundaries
so that's a great way of starting from
that 50 000
view in terms of what do
you have control over in your system
versus what are all those other external
interfaces that you
have to communicate with and when i say
external there you know some of those
may be
effectively internal to an organization
but they're
external to your specific team so
that's a great way of starting with a
threat model exercise
and in reality there's going to be other
trust boundaries within the system that
you are developing
and so once you feel like maybe you've
got a
good handle on the threats that
are to interfaces outside of your
control you may then want to
zoom in to certain areas of your system
and then kind of repeat that activity
again
in order to get full coverage at all
levels okay fantastic and
when you do these exercises what are the
number one things that come up
i wouldn't say that there's like a list
of five things that
always come up because it really depends
a lot on
individual systems i think
in a lot of cases you know you can see
just
basically oh we aren't maybe encrypting
a connection
or what authentication do we have on
either side of a trust boundary
i guess on that one in particular it's
quite interesting
a lot of people understand that
when you are communicating with a system
that you are
not in control of you need to
authenticate that connection in some way
shape or form
but you also need to think about whether
that is one-way authentication
or two-way authentication and
a lot of people will automatically think
about
say a user spoofing
an identity to their service
but what about the other way around can
an attacker
create a service that is spoofing
something that a genuine user would
interact with
so and that's where that structure of
threat modeling can really help because
it forces you to ask the question from
multiple different angles
and even on directions which you
wouldn't normally think about
yeah it's fascinating i suppose i'm i'm
trying to come up with a principled way
to give people actionable advice and the
reality is it's very complicated because
if you did draw that map out
and and then you do a threat modeling
exercise it's
it's so overwhelming that in a way
you're just randomly
sampling from the various different
threats and if you did the threat
modelling exercise five times you might
get slightly different results maybe
you'd get some some overlap but
there's also something to be said for
guiding principles when you architect
these systems i mean
i've been around the sun quite a few
times and i know to
have isolation between environments and
you know minimum kind of um
privilege and for example on the cloud
providers they have
v-net service endpoints and we can
reduce our attack surface by not having
any
anything publicly available and stuff
like that so there's a certain amount
you can do but
what i'm what i'm getting from this
conversation though is that ultimately
there are so many different um kind of
back doors into your castle
and all of them could become a kind of
vector of attack at some point later on
yeah it is a huge problem space and i
guess it
keeps us security folks employed and the
more complicated a system gets
the more components there are in a
system the more chance there is for
there to be a floor in one of those
components
and whilst there's a number of
activities that can
help discover those flaws such as
undertaking
code reviews or automated code scanning
or
doing application assessments or
penetration testing
yeah these are all good things that form
part of an overall
security assurance for a system threat
modeling is just
a another one of those tools in the
toolbox to help identify where
there might be flaws i mean you
mentioned things like
adopting architectural standards or best
practice
absolutely yeah making sure that a
development team is
aware of say the o wasp top 10 for
web application security vulnerabilities
really really important
because you would like your developers
not to code the vulnerabilities in the
first place
rather than discovering them later and
so yeah absolutely use all of those
resources
and if you have used all those good
resources and you've got
really switched on security-minded
developers
then when it comes to do threat modeling
you're probably going to be left
scratching your heads because
you feel like you've covered everything
off but again that structured
methodology that comes with
threat modeling really helps to tease
out some of those items that
you may not have thought about already
yeah it's fascinating
and as you say it is it's a
multi-layered approach it's like a huge
sandwich
and many of the things can even be
automated as you're saying you can do
things like linting and the unit tests
and the
the code scanning and there are some
principles i think around
minimizing the chance of data egress or
malicious code execution and
standardizing on
the images you use if you know when
you're running code in containers and
and so on but
as you point out it's actually it's it's
it's very
kind of multi-factorial and and there
are so many different perspectives on
this
absolutely and each of these different
tools in the toolbox
serve a different purpose you can't just
say
oh well i can't be bothered to do code
scanning or threat modelling
i'm just going to pay a penetration
tester to have a go at my app and see
whether they find something
each tool does a different thing uh
likewise
code scanning it will tell you whether
you have
say i know a sql injection vulnerability
in your code
but it won't tell you if you have a
fundamental flaw in your business logic
you can have effectively secure code but
actually
the application is still inherently
insecure because
i think maybe it allows an unauthorized
person to see
information that they shouldn't just by
changing one value somewhere
and again threat modelling one of the
the key pieces that helps with
is identifying where there's flaws in an
overall
architecture or design because it
encourages that qualitative conversation
amongst developers
rather than i guess the push button
activity
of a code scan um or a
an application assessment absolutely and
one of the things that we're getting to
as well is i'm a big believer that many
eyes make shallow holes
and what you're talking about is
diversity because one person might say
oh
why don't we just we don't need security
people why don't we just have developers
that can code securely in the first
place and it's not as simple as that you
need to have different perspectives
and that's part of what the threat
modeling exercise can do
but one thing that does worry me about
centralized security is
it can just become overwhelming because
you folks see so many different exploits
you want
behind the scenes you're almost like
compiling a list of best practices and
guidance
and that list is probably longer in
length than the bible
so so then you need to create a level of
abstraction to hide away some of that
complexity from from my perspective
because
it can become so overwhelming that i'll
be discouraged from even
interfacing with security so how do you
kind of deal with that information
overload
so i think as you say you know hiding a
lot of the
low level detail off the bat
is quite helpful so for example i won't
tell you about
the 50 different ways that
maybe an attacker might be able to
establish persistence on a machine
they've just compromised
because there's no value in in you
necessarily knowing that
however there's maybe a handful of
things that
can be done from a design or
architecture point of view
that help either make it less likely or
less damaging
if one of those things were to happen
and so absolutely by abstracting a lot
of that away
it then makes a developer's job a lot
easier
and that's why we say things like
encrypt information if you're
transferring across the internet
that's really simple nice and easy and
maybe we might also say
oh and make sure you use tls version 1.2
or 1.3
you don't need to know what tls 1.2 or
1.3 really means
and the differences and the protocol
versions you just need to know hey i
need to use that one
because if i don't do that then my
information is at risk and
i don't need to tell you all the details
about the different types of attacks on
different uh versions of ssl and
different ways of downgrading
connections and all this kind of
complexity that an attacker might use
you just need to know hey i need to do x
and y and i should be good on
you know 95 of the cases around this
particular area
amazing and it's been such a pleasure um
talking with you by the way folks so
andy has an amazing youtube channel
all about cyber security and he's
actually working on an entire series
around ai security
coming up ah thanks for the plug there
tim yeah so
most of the content i create is quite
technical in nature
exploring some of the techniques and
tactics that attackers use to compromise
systems
and but yeah as you say yeah got a
little project on the go in the
background looking at some more
ai security related threats uh it may be
a month or two before that starts to
reach the the eyes of the audience but
uh yeah
do uh get subscribed if you want to see
that as soon as it starts coming out
absolutely make sure you subscribe i've
learned so much actually from watching
andy's youtube channel
hi i'm andy and welcome to my little
corner of youtube
i create cyber security videos designed
to help develop intermediate level
skills
my main series attack detect defend
demonstrates the variety of techniques
used by hackers
and what can be done to detect and
prevent attacks
i've published video walkthroughs of a
few capture the flag competitions
and i have a few other cool projects in
the works coming soon
if all this sounds right up your street
take a browser a few videos
and consider subscribing
oh